yo what's up it's Millie's and you can
catch me on the bootleg cab podcast
special guest in here Bronco six on the
way April 7th April 7th
yo Milly's is here man welcome sir my
boy yeah I'm looking forward to uh a
potential NBA Finals matchup between
your Celtics and my Phoenix Suns if KD
is healthy I love that I love to go in
there get that sweep and just celebrate
it's a sweet huh no I don't know you
know four to one or something like that
we're overdue for a title though
I don't think so I think you guys have
enough titles to last you you know who's
overdue for a title the Phoenix Suns you
know how many we have how many zero oh
yeah no you gotta stay that way for a
while because like Jason Tatum gotta
have his run you know he's having to run
Taylor Brown they gotta have that right
yeah anyway I've seen you [__]
courtside at all the Celtics games yeah
what are those tickets run you oh okay
how does that work
it's like you just got to be like really
iconic and influential in the city of
Boston and then to hold you down it'd be
crazy for them to not give you free
tickets right yeah I don't want to talk
about it too much though you know
because it's like
to pay ten thousand a pop so you're
getting free tickets Courtside that's
that's amazing is that through a player
through the pr or somebody at the
Celtics organization they just know
what's up they're like we gotta tap in
with the hottest rapper now honestly
like that's that's
um one of the greatest things that's
ever happened to me in my career as far
as like
you know it's dope selling out shows and
all of that [__] and you know everything
that comes with rap but I used to get
hyped when people would give me a
t-shirt right so to give me courtside
Celtics tickets to the finals
yeah come on stop wow and like I really
sat there me pissed and kiss watching
the Celtics with the Warriors as if I if
I had came back like if I had been in
another game we would have won again bro
and I got a Immaculate Courtside record
I think that's why they let me back like
that because they're like you're kind of
like the actual like leprechaun I am
lucky yeah yeah for sure you know they
should have flew you out to the Bay for
those [__] Warriors yeah they said we
would have won for sure something about
the energy you know but yeah that's like
one of the biggest accomplishments of my
life like thank my plugs so much and
just thank the organization they treat
me amazing yeah I remember last year I
sat Courtside for the first time
at a son's game and I was like oh this
is like a dream come true and you sat in
the balcony right yeah I mean I've sat
everywhere but I never sat Courtside
until last year and I was like this is
insane no it is different it's just like
you know I'm a are you like a die-hard
basketball fan I'm a die-hard Celtics
fan yeah so growing up like can you
imagine saying Die Hard Celtics fan and
you gotta understand like I really know
the experience like I'm from I'm from
two train stops away so we would get on
the green line and take it to Leach
mayor and watch Ron Mercer yeah crazy
all that Antoine Walker Antoine Walker
yeah man
shout out to Antoine that was the shots
of the Celtics man I remember watching
Antoine Walker as a kid and then he went
to the Timberwolves and kind of flamed
out but you know what was great about
the Antoine Walker Jersey is when
uh what's his name the other Walker came
to December walk Campbell came it was
the same number same last name so you
could bust out the OG Antoine Walker
Jersey it's the same thing it's fire so
it was a that was like a short-lived
moment but kind of a travesty that
Antoine Walker's Jersey isn't retired
because he kind of was like the best
player on the Celtics for at least three
or four years oh yeah yeah he made the
All-Star team hell yeah I think he made
the All-Star The Walker wiggle you
remember the Walker wiggle no I just
remember you do this one hmm
yeah uh so listen man uh how many
Blanco's are you gonna do seven seven of
them I'm capping it at seven
is that because it's like a just it just
feels right I mean God created the world
in six days and rested on the seventh
hmm
you had that the god number you know
it's the god number you have a seven on
your face as well yeah yeah yeah you
know my daddy died at seven seven all
right this new uh uh Blanco you somehow
got a Stan interpolation cleared
yeah what is the process of getting
Eminem clearance
so the process of getting an m m
clearance is not getting Eminem to clear
it it's getting Dido to clear it because
it was her vote and it was her original
sample nothing off of the stand sample
so when I came out with the [__] like
and told everybody I'm like I just
cleared the stand sample because to me
those words well people don't know that
that she was that song was her own song
sample that she sent it from her yeah so
basically how it happened I was I was
out here in La I laid this song you know
um
just on some freestyle [__] because I'm
really independent so I don't know how
it goes with uh clearing samples I stay
away from all of that right you know
what I mean I never even thought it
would be possible right so I laid this
song
um my man 10 is just on the iPhone real
quick did a uh a video of me like
singing this [__]
in the crib and you know it got millions
of views online so my distribution
perfect time music they were like
hitting me like yo this [__] got motion
I think we should try to clear it and
I'm like go ahead and he found some lady
who knows about clearance samples and
then she got it to Dido and Dido okayed
it you know took a little percentage of
the record and I mean not yeah and yeah
and we had it so a lot of my fans were
mad because the song was like short but
that's the way that I did it in the
studio because I'm like it's like a
freestyle for me to listen to or like to
put out on YouTube so by the time I got
this sample cleared I'm like [__] it
I'ma just put it out in this raw form
and I did an extended version that comes
with the albums that's the process of
getting an Eminem sample cleared you
just just get one of the records that he
sampled so you don't have to go through
him yeah yeah it'd be like if someone's
tried to clear it Sing for the Moment be
like it's not an Eminem song it's an
Aerosmith yeah yeah but I would still
say I was clear the thing for the moment
sample oh man you and Ray Sherman got a
song coming soon maybe me and Swae Lee
yeah we got a disc record coming against
against Slim Jimmy yeah that was kind of
a weird thing man I saw that I was like
why the [__] was somebody and I know
Jimmy he's a good dude I just I just
didn't understand like
I mean maybe it's just a way to promote
your own [__] but I don't understand the
thought process of [__] on somebody
else to promote your own [__] you know
what it was I think I think my [__] was
getting traction like my [__] was having
motion online well damn that was the
same thing that was their rollout like
we cleared the stand sample but I'm a
marketing guy so I already know that so
as soon as as soon as I cleared it I'll
put it out there yeah and you know sites
at rap started picking it up it started
going crazy right and
the next day
I saw like Swae Lee's Camp pushing his
[__] on Twitter Swae Lee cleared the
sample I'm like oh no they're panicking
they must have saw my my joint out there
and uh that's when my ship kept going
crazy on academics and it helps and it
just helps your [__] yeah Slim Jimmy
wrote about it and it brought more
awareness so you know salute thanks to
him for the free promo nah and I really
like them as a group I talked to Swae
Lee you know Swae Lee's cool and I could
never have beef with like race trimmer
that's like being a bully like that
right yeah you know who else on the new
album
um I got G herbo on there I got Jadakiss
I got burner I got Dave East big burns
on the album big burns on the album man
I'm trying to get him to shoot this
running gun you know cause burn like to
shoot running gun videos you gotta go to
the Bay man and now he's like big
billionaire burn so he's by the way he's
been big billionaire bro for sure like
no he's on like Forbes list like right
now now everyone knows he's telling it I
knew this [__] I was telling my homies
like a while ago but um I shot a run and
Gun on his album before where we just
you know ran around and shot the video
but now I'm I'm trying to do one with
him where I just follow him for two days
see like the life of burning
incorporated into the video but yeah
he's on there um man I'm gonna forget
people Sada James that's incredible
artist named Sada James you'll be
hearing of a uh
super talented I forget who else
G herbo you said that yeah me you yeah I
feel like you and Berner because Berner
likes to do collab albums with people
yeah he's like you know he's done now
I'd love to collab collab albums with
people I feel like it'd be kind of hard
if you and Verner did like a whole
little [__] six or seven pieces
that'd be hard I actually get fans that
come to my shows like in in Chicago and
different places and it'll be like yo I
met you through burn a lot of Mexican
guys
the Mexicans love burning for sure a lot
of Mexican fans I got through on burning
so what was did he reach out to you
um I got a I got a mutual acquaintance
with him um my man Tabo like a like an
OG from my city and somehow they linked
me with him but yeah it was all love and
then he was like come get on my album
you know I came to his session
I had to beat right there I wrote my
[__] right there it's got to feel dope
man because like you are not a new
artist by any means like it's like I'm
not a new artist but I'm a brand new
artist but we've told the story before
like I met you at South by Southwest in
like 2000 yeah I remember I was walking
home 14 probably I was walking home in
the streets drunk nobody here at the
same Hotel
no I think you yeah yeah you was in the
line for something we're we're at like a
hotel bar somewhere it was like it was
like by the valet or the bar at the uh
that hotel that's like I remember but I
can remember walking down Sixth Street
right lost yeah I remember walking down
Sixth Street and nobody knowing me you
know a lot of us like yeah a lot of less
tattoos but just nobody knew me anyway
now they recognize me through the mass
I'll be having a shasty mess like this
one you put hands in my pockets [__]
like this maybe like Millie's will be
like how bro but um yeah I remember I
remember seeing you because I was
walking down 6th Street nobody knows I
said that's bootleg cab I forget even
where I knew you from but you were doing
I mean I was kind of like back then I
was like on the blogs a lot with my
interviews and [__] yeah yeah they're
like two dope boy days yeah that's why I
love seeing your [__] go up because even
at the time to me you were like popping
right you know what I mean so now you
really popping
um but it's got to feel good to be on
such a long
journey of being a by taking this
Rapture serious to end up doing you know
records with some Legends and then
obviously
Lincoln with Snoop Dogg and you know
what I'm saying like there's like I feel
like you've had so many moments in the
last couple of years where like
you know do you feel like
validated I know you've always known
yeah but like to kind of get the peers
to kind of give you that cosign that's
got to mean a lot man yeah I picked up a
lot of cosine like I picked up a lot of
co-signs in rap
but then like I got co-signed by the
money hmm that's what that's the one
thing like I wasn't turning the profit
from this [__] yeah you were kind of
doing it I was doing it just getting by
like I would make money I've been
getting paid for features for 12 13
years right you know what I mean would
that would you say that was kind of more
the bread and the butter like I could
get features I I'm doing my shows to get
hot it wasn't no real money right you
know
and the second I did get a little real
money I just put more back into myself
the pandemic did it for me for real but
like I would say like yeah the
validation from you know whether it's
like you know I'm signing a kiss and I'm
like Snoop is like a big supporter of
mine and um just all these guys in the
game you know and and so so it's that
but then it's
see it reflecting in my bank account
like I got accountants now and [__] and
I'll be like damn like I really made it
like I shot a tear on a plane one time
like for real like I just had a crazy
day and I just shed a tear like I
couldn't believe it like because I was
really thinking I can't believe that I
was dumb enough to believe in this [__]
that I made happen like yeah I mean hey
but it's hard for some sacrifice yeah
it's hard work and sacrifice and I feel
like sometimes you just got to be dumb
enough to believe you know if that makes
sense yeah that's some real [__] I mean
you had a lot of I feel like you had a
lot of like like uh uphill battles to
fight being the white dude rapping about
Street [__] yo bro it's almost
impossible it's like an uphill battle on
roller skates when you think about it
like because I'm actually doing
something that's never been done correct
because you know we know all the
different type of rappers that came
through hip-hop
and there's never been a white rapper
with the street content they run around
with jewelry on really in the trenches
really moving around really co-signed by
the right people [__] right it just
hasn't happened correct ever ever ever
you know there's nothing close to it
except if you're looking out like my guy
like like Paul Wall in Houston right but
his content was more that Houston
contest it was more like braggadocious
yeah it wasn't like my [__] I'm telling
intricate Street stories to the point
where I'm talking about Nationwide
whether we're in Chicago Minnesota
Cyprus projects in East New York
wherever the [__] we at I got real
Street people Miami
yeah the way that you break [__] down
like I'm really embraced in the trenches
Nationwide
and um
people used to think like this [__] was
impossible and I'm still not like I've
never had editorial playlisting on
Spotify like that really hell no bro I
got 650 that like so there's still
things that give like I love Spotify and
I know y'all will give me all of my it's
coming because I learned to not be the
rapper to like burn a bridge and
complain so I'm not complaining I'm just
saying the other rappers three million
on Spotify yeah I got 650 000 without
one with one percent editorial playlist
right my shit's a little different you
know what I mean it's I mean you're
about to headline a tour yeah and I'm
about to sell out across the country
hard tickets so I had to do all my [__]
Kev I swear to God I had to do all my
[__] by just showing and proving because
the industry did not [__] with me I'm
gonna tell you something I never told
anybody in life
no major label ever reached out or
showed interest in me never never still
to this day I used to lie about it okay
no there's interest today of course
there is today on God in heaven there's
interest today but
I used to lie about it my whole career I
swear to God just to people though right
you know just be like I'll be in an
interview and be like yo so anything
going yeah you know a couple Majors
interested live betting more yeah like
or I used to you know chill with girls
and be like yeah so you know Atlantic
Records they were actually taught never
okay no major looked at me and I've been
grinding for 13 years and I watched all
their artists come and go like I watch
all these people who were right here
with me get signed they're gone I don't
know where they are I'm here you feel me
so would you even consider the major
route now never never I'd have to have
the most unique deal ever because once
you start feeling the feeling of your
catalog you know really residual income
here yeah bro I don't gotta like I you
know I'm I'm waking up on a certain
dollar amount regardless right because
of my catalog I couldn't imagine what
it's like to to not have a streaming
catalog and you only get these checks
and and then you live off those you're
pretty much living off because I'm like
really bad with money I got a big
Advance on my last [__] and I thought I
was rich rich rich rich rich rich last
time I was in California oh my God
because you know I never really had
money like that right I got that money
boy
we stayed in that we stayed in a house
for like
first thing we stayed in the house
somewhere in L.A with the with the
basketball court
[__] however much a night that is
it was like I don't know three four
thousand a night we stayed there like
not necessary yeah we yeah we stayed
there srts all type of cars I mean this
isn't is this a new chain here
this is new it is fairly new I think
serious huh yeah kiss just gave me this
chain this is through kissing Mazda you
know shout out to you with the free
chain and the free goddamn Courtside
finals tickets that's what happens when
you get successful you get free [__]
Jesus that's it that's fire hey we gotta
stop the interview real quick to tell
you about our family at Odd Socks baby
that's right shout out to Odd Socks
little Godfather sock right there
craziest licenses in the game the most
comfortable socks period And if you go
to oddsocksofficial.com right now use
the promo code bootleg you're gonna get
20 off at checkout now they also got the
underwear going on these are some Street
Fighter draws pop these boys open
check them out oh yeah oh yeah a little
Chun Lee versus Blanco
what
amazing
do you like you who so much that you'd
wear you who on your feet
there's people running around out here
with goddamn hot Cheeto jumpsuits right
now so of course you would shout out to
you who they got crazy licenses we
already mentioned Street Fighter
Coca-Cola Pepsi yes they got the they
got the boat there they got Pepsi and
Coca-Cola uh they also got Scarface
Breaking Bad WWE so many dope licenses
plus their Odd Socks Basics line which
are these just kind of the normal socks
in my opinion are the most comfortable
socks I've ever put on my feet
I promise you you gotta go to
autotoxofficial.com right now and use
the promo code bootleg save 20 off your
entire order all right so go do that
oddsoxofficial.com also want to give a
shout out to our family at hardean
that's right Harding the craziest
dispensary you've ever walked into in
your life Hardy in Las Vegas you got to
pull up follow them on Instagram Harding
underscore Las Vegas you see the Hat you
see the logo shout out to the family at
hardean if you're in Vegas you got to
stop off you got to go pick you up some
weed it is legal in Vegas tell them I
sent you they're gonna take care of you
all right uh make sure you follow them
Harding underscore Las Vegas the largest
selection of previous cannabis I've ever
seen in my life the best smelling place
I've ever walked into in my life they
have a signature scent that's [__]
insane so shout out to hardine go follow
him Hardy underscore Las Vegas check out
more info about them at
jardinlasvegas.com let's get back to the
interview
um so for you it would have to be a
unique deal to even think like so
because again yeah bro and you know not
to cut you off I'm sorry we're gonna do
it I really I really I almost got
disdained from major labels like when
the whole Slim Jimmy [__] happened my
thing was to them don't be mad at me
because you're on on a major and you got
to go through all this red tape to drop
I could drop tomorrow that's why I
really just pressed the button on the
shorter version because it's me it's
already done throw it out there yeah big
dog yeah um and it's like you know the
fact that none of them ever
um showed interest like now I just
really like [__] on them and and
just showing them like I just like
getting more successful and more
successful no booking agencies ever
picked me up you know what I mean no um
I just got that chip on my shoulder bro
I'm like I'm like a player who um who
did all four years in college and then
went and played in China for five years
they went played in Yugoslavia I was
gonna say you're like buddy Hill but
buddy Hill went to the league after four
years yeah that's what I'm saying but
then I came back and I dominate did the
NBA for three seasons and I'm on my
third season [__] like that I like that
and I'm not even gonna say dominated the
NBA but I'm like putting up but no
you're doing your thing yeah Lou
Williams right now
I like that
um so if you don't have a booking it's
like so did you book now yeah now I got
to book an agent but I'm just saying
like on the come up like there was just
nobody who saw it in me so like for for
everybody out there to understand like
oh my come up nobody ever saw it in me I
saw it in me I didn't care like no
matter how much rejection I had to face
I knew like I
I might be on some delusional [__] but
for some reason I believe in this and
I'm gonna keep going after it I'm gonna
keep going after it and I knew also I
had the work ethic to put in you know
and like you can't cheat a work ethic
you can't cheat you can't cheat anything
you can't cheat the work man and like
you can go viral you can there's like
these unicorn situations where people
might catch a tick tock and get signed
or it don't last like I learned all my
come up like I really learned young like
to not be jealous and to not be envious
because
you know everything isn't as great as it
looks you know on the outside right you
ended up uh working with mozzie which uh
obviously free mozzie yeah I think I put
you guys on text together the day we did
that interview yeah um you tell you told
me you're still keeping in contact with
him you wrote them in jail like talk
about your guys's relationship fast
forward a year and some change man so
it's so crazy because we did our
interview here you asked me who I would
work with if I could work with anybody I
said Mozzy this before meeting him
following on social media anything
so
yeah somehow we got we got in in touch I
think like I put you guys on a group
chat yeah and then on the spot yeah and
then and then a month later it happened
I came to Cali
I remember at the interview you were
like and it's the most people I've ever
seen in my studio I had like my whole
neighborhood with me when we went into
his [__] we went into his studio
and he did the song on the spot and then
he was like what y'all doing after let's
shoot the video which like a rapper
never says to you yeah nobody ever wants
to shoot the video Kiss actually said to
me he was like damn when's the last time
you did a song for a rapper that you're
bigger than and then asked him to shoot
the video no you were like yeah he was
like I was like yeah he was like man you
got to appreciate that type of [__] so
yeah we did that and that's a classic
song for me Kev like that [__] rings off
in London that [__] rings off in L.A New
York Boston I mean they sing that [__]
that's big bro yeah shout out Mozzy man
real guy somebody else who's kind of a
white guy speaking about Street [__]
that's doing well right now is OT shout
out to OT the real yeah
um I know you guys have uh have worked
together what's uh
would you guys ever do a joint project
together or would that be a little too
expected
um no I would do a joint project with
him definitely when the time is right
because he's hard bro yeah he's one of
them MCS like when you're a high level
rapper
it's a difference from doing songs with
you know certain people certain people
you really gotta lock in like you can't
[__] with them there's certain
rappers I could get in the studio I
don't really gotta give you the craziest
[__] because I'ma still be top tier up
here without trying [__] with
somebody who's like this you gotta
really like lock in and pay attention
like if you listen to our back and forth
song everybody should go listen to that
that's I forget what it's called but go
listen to it and um you know that's like
verbal sparring that's just fire would
you and Dave do a sequel tier yeah yeah
we're working on that you're working on
it yeah we're working on that nice he
just sent me the first record for real I
like it man who else from your area or
Boston just I guess kind of just that
whole area would you uh say is on the
come up that you're [__] with that we
can shut some light on
um I'm gonna say that there's a there's
a there's a lot of people but I'm gonna
say G Nipsey for sure
um he's in here right now he's going
crazy
um he really had my city like my city
was already
feeling them involved and there's a lot
of kids from my city that kind of like
get mad at that like why you don't
support me too but I'm like you got to
get the city first get the city you know
so um yeah Gene Nipsey going crazy died
of the deal of my man
um jigs
and then uh man there's a lot of rappers
out of the trenches in Boston that are
going crazy obviously the the bigger
ones too like beer and you know Joyner
he is like an OG too people don't people
think she just popped off I'm like B has
been now we yeah that's what I'm saying
we if you look at Massachusetts the
rappers we all had the longest roads
yeah be it had a long road man the label
them
Joiner had a long I had a long road B I
had a long road because if you're from
Massachusetts you got to work three
times as hard because it's never been
done
I always wonder if you grow up there did
you like did anyone grow up listening to
Benzino I did
which because Benzino you would buy The
Source magazine back in the day and you
would he did have like a four page ad
for like the well like the thing you
understand when see I went to school in
Boston like I'm from Cambridge but I
went to school in Charlestown so like
when I'm 14
something around there that's when
I believe that Eminem and Benzino beef
is happening
and so I know different facts than other
people like I know Benzino and him is
like really like in the streets and like
they raw rappers and beat them up and
like so and NBA players
shout out to Paul Pierce Paul Pierce my
dog
um but it's like you know it's crazy
because when you have a different
understanding of somebody right like I
always feel like the fans of the fans
knew my real real real real real real
life like they would love me 20 times
more you know
um but I knew at the time like Benzino
and them are really on that type of time
right so even if his raps wasn't the
illest [__] in the world you kind of you
you believed it so it was more it's like
you ever had a brand new hang around and
he's a killer but he's not like a real
rapper but when he raps he's rapping
killish anything like this [__] hard
because you believe them right like I've
had a lot of those like guys I have
rappers like that that I believe to be
real killers like when I would listen to
MLP as a kid I'd be like
yeah these [__] I'll kill your
ass yeah but it hits different when you
know even like Fat Joe Like Fat Joe back
in the day after you hear all these
stories about Fat Joe [__] people up
and yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um so so I would say like yeah I
listened to some some Benzino but Emma's
my favorite though hmm yeah and what's
your favorite yeah and what's my
favorite so you were torn because you're
like the hometown I wasn't like touring
like I was like 90 Eminem like 10
Benzino but
I wouldn't just go against Benzino
because he's still from the 617 you know
what's your favorite uh Eminem album
um
this is it the um Welcome to The Eminem
Show Eminem Show yeah that's my favorite
the third one say goodbye to Hollywood
man when like and like just he raps and
like
I don't know but then I like The Slim
Shady
he said some of his most illest
intricate raps ever well like his first
joint and Slim Shady yeah but then he
got so introspective like from a rapping
perspective that Slim Shady LP is crazy
right but then the Eminem show
is incredible how like introspective he
got and [__] like that and I just think
he had the better records it's my
favorite M album yeah and then there was
Encore which was it then relapse
oh [__] has Eminem know who you are I
don't know man I'm not sure no [__]
it'd be kind of crazy [__] I feel
like he do yeah yeah I feel like I'm on
Drake's radar definitely because he's a
guy who um
you know Jake's really in tune with like
the rap [__] so how do you mean is there
anything that's happened where you think
like oh I'm on Drake's radar like
because of this because he likes
something people have told me [__] but
there's no like like concrete [__] right
you know that I can say but um
hopefully you know what I mean hopefully
I'm on M's radar too because like our
bodied a lot of Eminem beats my body a
lot of Drake beats [__] like that yeah
uh what is something because kiss is
kind of
I think kiss is one of them like
Executives that's a rapper that has kind
of like
played the background more than most
Executives and CEOs would if that makes
sense like I think kiss is like kind of
like
like you don't hear him like like
running around pushing so raspy you know
what I'm saying like like that like I
think kiss is like about his business
you know what I'm saying and I think a
lot of people sign artists
and I think that they can't get out of
the way to let an artist become bigger
than them yeah as to where I feel like
Kiss is like he would love for you to be
yeah that's the thing I I appreciate
about kiss the most because
he really just lets me like go like run
my own show type [__] with no ego you
know what I mean he just really likes
his best lets me like he understands my
program he loves like you know my camera
man he loves my team he understands
the thing that I got going and he just
lets me run my play you know like
egoless so and then I just call him like
when I need them
why do you think that some of the
industry [__] hasn't come around for you
like the editorial playlist or you think
it's just a timing thing or do you think
you got to work that much harder being a
white rapper what do you think it is
yeah I think it's people still might not
understand you know maybe I don't know
though I honestly I can't say because
it's the editorial playlist and it was
it's just
there's a couple of different things
like I never got put on like a festival
or no [__] like that yeah you've never
done rolling loud or nothing so I'll be
seeing that's what I'm saying because
everybody's [__] nobody's unrolling
that's what I'm saying and I could
outsell like let's go take it for ticket
sale some of them names at the bottom
rolling loud I'll be like who the [__]
man in the middle of rolling loud let's
go you know that hard ticket sale for
hard ticket sale
you feel me so do you give a [__] I mean
obviously you want to do rolling loud
but like does that [__] just motivate
you more yeah it just motivates me like
it's good like you can't give me
everything right now
you know
it means I still got a higher selling to
go like somebody saw the fact that like
I've had no editorial playlist and means
I got a super high sailing because I
could be maxed out right now one and
also did you have like real fans that
are hiring yeah I'm an apple music
[__] like I'm Apple musical
crazy
that's the streets though the streets is
on Apple music in the streets are they
yeah YouTube like if you do some [__]
with a real street artist their base is
going to come through YouTube and apple
music because you know what they got in
the streets iPhones
they're not signing up for Spotify
yeah I'm not saying you're gonna hit the
button that says 10.99 before you go
open the app and hit download yeah so
you're saying college and [__] the Apple
music crowd is more of the streets yeah
um these are the streets on Spotify but
I'm just saying like that that like yeah
the [__] is kind of like
detached from the end I'm on Spotify
because that's where I got to listen to
Joe Rogan he ain't nowhere else so
official they got they I catch my clips
on YouTube though you gotta get the
whole episode hey we gotta stop the
interview real quick to tell you about
the homies at mybookie bet on anything
anywhere anytime at mybookie.ag and
check this out if you sign up right now
with the keyword bootleg you're gonna
get a first deposit bonus up to a
thousand dollars and that's not it
if you sign up with that keyword bootleg
not only will you get that first deposit
bonus up two thousand dollars but you're
also gonna get a free 50 000 sweet 16
bracket entry so many ways to win at
mybookie.ag I've been using them for
about 10 years now trust me when I say
I'm not co-signing them because they're
dropping the bag I mean that's nice but
I've been literally using my bookie for
the better part of the last decade to
put all my sports bets in to play a
little online roulette a little black
jack a little craps it's all there they
got the live casino they got so much
going on look March Madness is where
it's at right now you can get down with
that uh sweet 16 the elite eight the
NCAA Final Four all of it NBA season in
full effect baseball is about to kick
off get in on the action bet on anything
anytime anywhere right now with my
bookie so sign up at mybookie.ag use
that promo code bootleg right now for
that first deposit bonus up to a
thousand dollars and a free 50 000 sweet
16 bracket entry hey also shout out to
the homies at Bluetooth man don't forget
if you're dealing with erectile
dysfunction in if your penis is not
functioning correctly
it's a little flaccid you're trying to
get it a little hard a lot of hard
rather Bluetooth is where it's at a lot
of people ask me you always talk about
Bluetooth does it work yes it works all
right uh listen it has the same active
ingredient as Viagra and as Cialis but
it's in a chewable form all right it is
sent right to your door uh in a discrete
package it's a great thing man go to
bluetooth.com right now you use that
promo code bootleg right now you're
gonna get a month supply for free of
Bluetooth why not have some better sex
okay seriously uh there's so many other
ways you can get down too because they
just dropped the Bluetooth mint flavor
which is the same active ingredient as
Levitra just so many things we can do
here uh and look when you go to
bluetooth.com and you sign up with that
promo code bootleg they're gonna
literally send it straight to your crib
for free five dollars in shipping you
get a month supply for free now how does
it work one you don't need to go to any
doctor's appointments it's all handled
online with an online pharmacist you
don't have to worry about going and
sitting in a waiting room to go discuss
your dick with some strange dude or
chick hmm maybe you're into that I don't
know with that being said it's an
awkward situation all right if you're
dealing with erectile dysfunction all
you need to do is go to bluetooth.com
right now use the promo code bootleg and
you'll get one month supply for free
zero dollars right to your door your
wife will even never know it even
happened you know what I'm saying maybe
you've been a little embarrassed you're
tired of piping down that same old bra
that you've been sleeping with for the
last 35 years put a little pep in your
step man take a Bluetooth use that promo
code bootleg bluetooth.com and try it
for free you watch Joe Rogan I do but
like just the clips like it's a lot like
it's like a three hour comment you just
what you do is you just download one and
then on a flight you just throw that
[__] on
and then by the time you land it's over
I don't got that time bro you're sitting
on a plane I gotta do other [__] on the
plane what do you do on a plane that
like not that like I listen to like
various assortments of music and then
like I watch Like whatever's the best
movie and then I text people and then I
try to go to sleep and then I do [__]
like that like I can't I got too much
add to just sit down and just hear like
these two boys just two dudes just
talking here two dudes like it's crazy
just shooting this [__] for three hours
oh [__] oh man
um well listen the seventh is when the
album drops you already have like the
the bones or the thought process of even
like approaching Blanco seven or or any
idea when you we could even see that you
think it'd be next year I'ma drop
something before and then I'm gonna you
know come with this [__] that that
really ends at I'm trying to get it like
a yeah I'm gonna get a big situation I
might need your help getting that for
sure you guys uh you and Dave are close
to finishing the the follow-up
I wouldn't say close but it's at the
same time it's easy for us to do that
how many songs you guys sitting on
together
um [__] like three oh yeah yeah do like
four more yeah good well seven packs got
a bunch of [__] yeah
um Talk to Me growing up give me your
top five best albums ever your favorite
don't got to be like just your personal
favorite
oh all right Prodigy H and I see okay
okay Prodigy Asian eyes favorite
Alchemist beat ever on there keep it
down like that album yeah I love that
album yeah he was talking to [__] like
you could just feel his confidence
confidence kind of like radiating
through
the music um let's go
Tim this is tough bro like all right
childhood yeah um Eminem The Eminem Show
okay life after death life after death
is the best album out of everything
though I think it's the best video no
out of all rap music that ever been
created life after death is
Superior like there's like rap albums
and there's like life after death okay
okay all right so just getting that
clear so I don't agree but life after
death I respect it The Eminem Show H and
I see
oh
[Music]
I'm gonna go carter
Carter won oh that's the right one yeah
what you know about that people be
thinking it's Carter 2 Cottage two is
fire Carter 2 did not age as well as
Carter one caught the one he got in his
bag no I think if you listen to both
Carters back to back right now Carter 2
does not age as well I love Carter 2-0
because he got on them Soulful beats and
he went really crazy for sure so but
like Birdman Jr come on man I miss my
dog what you know about Birdman Jr oh my
God that's what made that's one of the
songs that like inspired me to go
[__] ballistic on it sounds crazy
when he said [__] that I'm going in yeah
oh my God you sleep in the field for
trying the dude I'll bust your head to
the meat turn your mind to fool that's
Food For Thought think I ain't lying to
you a liar's body and she'd set fire to
my tires body and see put the tires to
him make him feel the Escalade put his
feet in the blade yo oh my God I'm the
heating the blade it was like when he
flows and she was just like unconscious
like I actually think that like that
song is like he's unconscious and it's
just going like this [__] [__] I
just try to listen I listen to Carter 2
on a road trip recently and I was like
man Carter won aged better Carter 2 is
solid but I think Carter one and three
aged way better I think Carter too damn
Kev you're like ill yeah yeah ill for
knowing like Birdman Jr though I mean I
was I was working at Best Buy when that
shirt came out I bought it don't get it
twisted people not gonna say that record
I mean that's the one on that album
um wasn't uh so that's four go DJ go DJ
was on that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah miss my dogs so so I got I got I
got Wayne Carter one
Prodigy eight and I see big life after
death
um Eminem Show and let's go
um let's go let's go all eyes on me I
like it yeah
how crazy you did I just see the white
boy Ricky guy hosting the club somewhere
I'm not gonna front look right I was at
a Celtics game
and
I'm saying Courtside and somebody I got
a lot of respect for he just facilitates
like celebrities and [__] like that he
hits me and said yo I want you to meet
my man white boy Rick he's at the game
looked over I seen a white dude with a
bust down chain and [__]
I'm like
is he a federal informant
if I watch the same movie we all watched
and then I asked my man like wasn't he
playing people in jail and [__] like I I
had to do like respectfully bro because
I really respect the person who brought
it to me like and he actually don't give
a [__] it's just people like it's coming
through Boston and they're like uh this
is this guy yeah this is so-and-so you
know what I mean he got so much [__]
going on
but I was like respectfully bro anybody
else you I would love to get introduced
to but I I don't want to be introduced
to him
I didn't even so I always get my like
Boston gangster movies confused
because there was the guy uh who they
found like way later Whitey Bulger
Whitey Bulger yeah but that's nothing
like no no no but so understand like as
much movies as I've consumed and not
being from Boston and not really yeah I
just confused the two I was like wait I
thought he was [__] dead or some [__]
like I was like oh no he got out because
he snitched
yeah yeah because Whitey Bulger was like
he was like he he got away forever
because then they barely find him when
he was like old as [__] like yeah Whitey
Bulger was like a federal informant too
oh so they both snitched yeah both
legendary snitches from Boston no
they're not no white boy is from Detroit
white boy Rick is from Detroit yeah see
this is me just assuming all white
gangsters come from Boston look at me
being racist kind of
I just assumed white boy Rick guy from
Boston no probably like
70 or something like Whitey Bulger yeah
was serious he caught like 80 something
smacks or something like they wanted to
charge them with 80 smacks was that the
Johnny Depp played him in the movie yeah
um what's it called black black masses
Black Mass yeah yeah Whitey Bulger was
serious what's the best Boston movie The
Town the town
followed by The Departed you know what's
another good movie that's not a gangster
movie
the movie where they talk about uh the
Boston Globe they snitched on all the
preachers raping all the kids they want
to [__] uh it won a [__] Golden
Globe what's it called uh Oscar what's
it called it's got Ray Donovan's in it
the guy who plays you know Ray Donovan
on Showtime
what's the name of that [__] movie
Lee Schreiber is in it anyway it's about
like how like the newspaper in Boston
now I remember blew the lid off I think
my mom watched that [__] yeah it's crazy
man yeah I like the yeah the talent is
probably number one the town to me is
just like super iconic like with the nun
masks man like if you really know like
it's an action movie but it's real
because Charlestown is the number one
place where like I think at one point
ninety percent of all armored truck
robberies in the USA were linked back to
Charlestown really yeah so it's all
there's one neighborhood and you went to
school there I went to school there and
Cambridge is five to ten minutes from
Charlestown five minutes in the car you
know what I mean so it's like I really
grew up knowing these kind of these kind
of kids and [__] that you know their
fathers are bank robbers and they're
robbing banks and it's just that's that
[__] they do you know so
um there's a guy like Millie's actually
celebrate St Patrick's Day
yeah yeah sometimes but like I've been
actually trying not to drink like this
year like that like do you pinch your
homies if they're not wearing green or
is that hella positive no no no no no no
no I don't do all of that I don't do all
that I got a splash of Irish in me but I
don't you know I don't go too crazy like
that I mean you got to [__] you know
yeah yeah you're you're the you're
you're the lucky charm if you will for
the Celtics apparently they better start
giving you more [__] tickets that's a
fact the Knicks gaming tickets too they
did yeah the Knicks gave me free tickets
to watch the Celtics I need to bring you
to Arizona just get a bunch of free
tickets from the [__] sons
Jesus anything's possible yeah uh well
listen man the new album it drops on the
7th of April yeah Blanco six yeah g
herbo's on the album yeah Davies
Jadakiss yeah
so many people
uh a lot of people
tour starts when
the toy starts May 5th in Boston House
of Blues is already sold out I'm sorry
then we go to New York then we have not
been to the House of Blues in Boston a
few times big [__] venue I saw Travis
Scott there big dog venue you hear that
name Jeezy was there yeah yeah
I went to a few shows there it's right
by uh Fenway right yeah yeah
bro I used to DJ in Boston and uh in
[__] uh yeah Providence I want to
give you your flowers on camera too
you've been grinding forever like you're
like a positive human being who just
goes out gets after it you connect
rappers you're really [__] embedded
in this hip-hop [__] thank you buddy and
I see you going up and it makes me happy
when I see your [__] going up I
appreciate you bro well listen go get
the album go get some concert tickets
how many dates
14. congrats man more to be added but
14. and let's um let's sell out Phoenix
let's sell out Phoenix God damn it
boom